c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
et les vacances c'était des vacances en
corse quand j'avais quand j'avais 13 14
ans quand on commence à découvrir
comment se découvrir les filles c'était
et pour qu'on avait au club med honnête
et on rentrait super tard le soir afin
super tard on pourrait vous que cette
équipe est retardé sa dette de près de
trois heures et on avait bu lui du mali
debout à nana et on te croyais et des
grands c'était génial
ces textes et mes premiers flirts et
j'ai pas fait que c'est dégueulasse la
main
personne en vacances était l'agneau je
me suis coincé en fait je me suis coincé
deux existent dans une soupe dans un
fauteuil et les basques ou des débats
school ex sur le fauteuil du coup je me
suis pété le frein vous avez le du sang
plein le tee shirt blanc et on n'a que
peu d'éléments rêviez intervenu dans ce
n'est ces thématiques qui séné d'ouf
vous allez crever
[Musique]